you've probably noticed that I've been
missing a lot of shows recently and I
want to let you know that this trend
will continue for the near future in
fact the Matt Walsh show will be on
Hiatus for the next three weeks
returning on July 17th and there's a
very good reason for this extended
absence uh actually there are three
reasons because I'm currently working on
three major projects I'm very excited
about I can't tell you anything else
about them right now unfortunately all I
could say is that you know what the
daily wire we don't want to just comment
on culture we want to make culture and
that's currently what I'm in the process
of doing I'll be back on July 17th with
my regular Daily Show which will
actually be daily again if you can
believe it and I promise we're going to
come out of the gate swinging on July
17th so you don't want to miss that make
sure you tune in soon after that you'll
begin to see what else we've been up to
around these parts a lot of very
exciting things on the horizon stay
tuned make sure you come back here on
July 17th I'll have a lot to say see you
then Godspeed